all right today's topics masculinity is
a trap which is why more men should wear
skirts before we roll their eyes let's
hear the argument clothes traditionally
worn by women are becoming part of the
mainstream of men's fashion and helping
break the straightjacket of prescribed
roles men's clothing norms are mired in
misogyny women wearing pants is powerful
I mean at some point it was strong for a
woman to wear pants but I don't think it
represents that anymore you see a woman
in pass you don't think oh wow
she's daring she's wearing no like we
don't care I digress however the minute
a man puts on a dress it's disgusting so
what are you saying men are strong women
are disgusting I'm not its quality
journalism it is said that so many men
are petrified about seeming effeminate
it is sad that it is not a socially
acceptable for men to experiment with
fashion the same way women camp 2019 is
a year men will start wearing skirts I
certainly hope so masculinity is a
straitjacket it is high time that more
men broke free
so another article by the Guardian came
out and it's from Moore when it says I'm
a womanist and my boyfriend in support
of me wore a dress and I found myself
unexpectedly uneasy with his new
fondness for feminine frocks a reaction
that challenged the progressive ideals
I'd prided myself on for decades I
thought long that I was contributing to
a progressive shift in how we define
masculinity finally allowing men to be
emotional and vulnerable or to ask for
help or to hug their male friends or to
wear dresses I imagined him skiing down
Mount Saint Helens the legendary rag
concealing his chiseled calves and heart
and quadriceps and stained strained to
find it in an appealing vision it was
too much even for him yeah cuz you roll
meds that while it wasn't a traction at
first sight with Ian his closet full of
feminine gear put a tiny dent in his
desirability from the very beginning of
our relationship intellectually I
enjoyed what ian was projecting gender
norms and expectations but physically my
desire didn't match it makes sense when
you thought about something you were
romanticizing that thing you went
for that dude because of his masculinity
and I'm not saying all women are like
that whatever floats your boat some
people are not gonna mind some people
are gonna mine but you're the type of
person that I want a masculine man
that's just what it is it's actually
okay to want someone with a beer to want
someone with six-pack that's what you're
attracted to there's other things you
know after the shower honest but things
that you're gonna be attracted to you're
attracted met the man man which is fine
so once you change that and it fit
whatever you romance in your head and no
longer was what it was throws like
whatever you meet a man you have a crush
and then you imagine how it would be to
be with that crush oh yeah
have you seen Brad oh yeah I seen Brad
at work you haven't had a conversation
too deep but all of the information that
you have from seeing them cross the room
you start to imagine thing which is all
right it's supposed to be like that you
start imagine a bunch of things
oh I don't smell it I don't know how he
talks but I imagine I yeah a big deep
voice and it's like that who is hands I
just imagine him doing a bunch of things
to you while you touching yourself
that's fine and the day comes
that's meet Brad and you talk to Brad
and you're like right is an idiot the
reason why you have a disappointment
it's not because of Brad right didn't do
right actually didn't do anything
hmm it's whatever you thought I'm Brad
that gives you that disappointment it's
a bit what happened here what happened
there is that she romanticized her idea
of what it would be if you would open up
if it would be a little bit more like
this a little bit more like that
Oh half dress be daring that's nice and
then reality struck and boom
nature happened what you were actually
attracted to happen and it was not
represented in front of you the thing
that happened is that whenever romance
and we romanticize things we don't think
about all the little fast facets of
everything we have this just general
idea of the thing and then we go with
that
but sometimes
details it's really in the details when
Fifty Shades of Grey came out everybody
was like I would love a powerful
businessman rich that would take
advantage of me and a few years later
happen Weinstein you didn't think about
all the facets but he's the same dude oh
yeah except Weinstein is not Christian
great and he don't look that good guys
do it too it's gonna be much much more
physical yes I know I'm generalizing
don't at me guys is gonna be like that
okay we're gonna be chilling and every
good seal girl past in a sundress in a
sundress what happened is that we're
gonna see this thing going on all right
I don't need to be more explicit you
know what I'm talking about
this right here going on let's walk oh
and now I'm sorry to romanticize what
this would be and how it would happen
physical where I feel like woman that's
more than the feelings and stuff like
that where when it actually happens
there's more chances of being
disappointed whereas real like it was
not that good at least we got some when
your whole scenarios doesn't go to plan
it's different if you plan a wedding and
you Myranda sighs what a wedding is and
it doesn't go according to plan
disappointment and shoes hmm that's what
I think about that I mean if you want to
wear a dress I don't care if you want to
wear skirt I don't care if you want to
say that men could do better by wearing
more skirts and dresses okay
I just always laugh whenever women try
to tell me what their ideal man is like
and I'm like two lines because we can
say whatever you want we can tell
ourselves we want a good man and we can
date and abusive boyfriends afterwards
okay what you say and how you act aren't
always in accordance and what I've
learned from my personal dating life is
that women can preach whatever they want
out there but behind closed doors they
like something different I know because
I always get called a woman-hating etc
etc and my detractors often love to have
debates with me and then behind closed
doors they're just
I'm said what okay that was you talking
not so just a girl adding a little extra
over like a little bit of pressure on
the side of her day yes women and you do
a little date they like to throw on a
little extra meanings so I remember
initially I was very shocked by how
there was like a juxtaposition between
how people presented themselves out
Doorly and how much of like an activist
they were you know that mean like
whatever they preached about Baha'i like
you like very loudly my girls always
like whoa okay you you like this out
here and so early on I just realized I
can't trust what women say when it comes
to what they say they wanted a man
because a lot of people claim to have
all these fancy ideas don't live by them
and they don't look for them in their
partners and you have seen countless
articles from women saying I don't know
what it is
despite being so progressive I like
gendered norms despite being so
progressive I like a mainly man I like a
man with a beard I like a man who's a
little more stoic I like a man who's
very emotionally reserved and so you can
signal whatever you want with your mouth
but men are peeping into what your
actions say and we're like all right
well if that's what it takes for me to
get a girl then I'm gonna just do that
and so even here this woman is in a
relationship with this man she sees him
in a dress and viscerally she can't stop
herself from being unattractive to him
and I don't think that's very strange
the idea don't match the feeling no
because you see what we always say I
want to be protected I want a man who's
bigger stronger than me bah blah blah
you see a man in a dress and
inadvertently it sends a different
signal now some of you might say why
can't a man in a dress be stronger
bigger this and that I don't make the
rules I just play by them now if you
guys want change the rules
feel free spend the rest of your day but
don't tell me to sacrifice my potential
dating pool because you want to change
society if that's what you want to do
you do you think I personally don't care
about wearing dresses so it's not a hill
I'm gonna dial mm-hmm
bill Porter could wear dress yeah he
knows how to wear dress in your opinion
I think it looks stupid but you're
allowed to think he looks good in it I'm
like hey do you think right and I'm not
gonna bite my way to see nothing but my
whole point being if you want to have
those ideas that's fine some of us
really like gender norms and we've
accepted it
you consider straitjacket for me it's
just a healthy fence around my home
that's not I know I'm mad at that right
mad at that I locked my front door might
be a straitjacket to you might be too
much security for me right along
there's no Liberty well you're locked in
no I I got the keys yeah I've had a
quick laugh with this article it was
just funny to me to just have these two
articles back-to-back I understand the
girl because the idea was not matching
the things you cannot control you know
with visceral inside and you're like I'm
attracted to that that's what makes me
go on yeah I get that girl I get how you
got that way I know the other day you
should question why you feel that way
and if you feel like it's coming from a
bad place and dress that but otherwise
it's okay live your life it's okay at
least that's what I think about this
when they said when we say toxic
masculinity
we don't mean oh man we don't mean all
the masculinity we just mean the traits
that are toxic therefore we call it
toxic now I get that but right there
that's the next step saying masculinity
is a straitjacket to me you want to be
effeminate whether you choose or you are
clever these are some people choose to
be mm-hmm
that's you go ahead live your life you
want to be masculine or you choose to be
masculine I'm talking about guys and
girls mm-hmm whether you masculine or
you choose to be masculine that's on you
if I see let's say someone like young ma
you know I mean am I gonna ask all the
girls to be like that no but if you
choose to be like that it's okay if the
man is effeminate fine
do you am I gonna ask all man to be like
that because the masculine teat no no I
accept oh do you I'm not gonna impose
nothing on you and call what you are
toxic or a straitjacket and I'm gonna
try to erase it because people are
saying that there's a gauge and they try
to make men more feminine and stuff like
that and I was like man
guys are tripping but I the more I look
at it and I see articles like that pop
up like it pops up in my feet nice and
stuff like there are people sent it to
me and I more and more I'm like they
trying to push that thing but maybe
we're not seeing the full picture so
this is your opportunity leave your
comments below we'll take a look at them
and if you guys got some great points
we'd love to have a conversation so
that's it for today's video
[Music]